hello and welcome to see you playing
iteration about the sim team sperian
probably yeah really playing twice that
sounds and probably I play them more
often on all their accounts so we like
them play them a lot pretty sure wallet
okay so we have a Quincy two nums oh
that yeah that got a distinct Queens
gambit type of flavor so how to play
here I think I probably have to get the
Korean out of the C value anyway so
let's do that okay so Queen a7 is
answered by be five okay rooh ka the
screen c7 so okay I could have gone to a
six actually mmm that would have been
interesting anyway anyway let's see if I
can be retained in a little bit with
this move the night a seven-point is
hanging
caption 196 is also and also whoa he
just decides to take uh-huh hmm that
looks nice for white it's not just the
two bishops but also the light squares
look like they're a somewhat tender
Queen a four for example coming up
Bishop g5 is also a pretty bad threat
okay um be sure to five it's not that
convincing actually love laughter d8
also Queen a form and also 94-94 also
move but that day I can maybe take and
now okay this is the kind of position
where I can easily spend too long and
then lose on time this is not bad here
after work the eighth i have bishop a
six ok this is why just that probably
okay now nite nite moves come into
consideration okay let's go find on the
move
you
want to keep the key pressure here on b6
and d 6 square yeah so you for now or
let's go
not sure yeah not quite sure what i'm
doing now him
hmm yeah maybe five and then the night
36 bits yeah okay not sure
hmm simply didn't take it hmm to do that
doubling here probably shouldn't forget
about my back rank but maybe I'm maybe
h4 is something that I could play could
be an interesting move to support an
attack but also give me some some
additional well then he s got 94 maybe
94
okay after play move k no 94 angling for
f4 here
just at the moment where I cannot play
and pawn to f4 every night before that's
bad it's really bad okay there's one of
those games again where you look after
which a marquee computer shows you how
you could have killed the other guy
quite obvious that that was possible
now I know I'm losing the queen now but
to other most didn't didn't help either
what did I do wrong yeah Rocky III Rocky
one was probably too lame probably too
lame yeah just take the Queen buddy
what's the big deal iam check
ok it's fairly easy win for black can
just push push his pawns now okay Leila
then I'm actually entering jacket still
dis that gives me some glimmer of hope
maybe a three wins anyway of it I know
it doesn't actually I've got g4 check
let's go in now I don't think so does he
doing here check soon it's not right
check
check check check check mate yeah for
the city game completely silly game
first I'm blundering and I'm giving the
Queen then he blunders it back and check
and it wasn't clear earlier I'm probably
better here right yeah I'm better you
chat have to take with the other rogue
check just just take stuff yeah but ok
the thing that interests me is how i got
from that fantastic position into that
credit position yeah i mean this looks
really terrible they are funny enough
computers says this position is equal so
I don't know anything about chess it
seems black has a completely desolate
night on b8 why I've got a night on d6
and still this should be equal what a
strange game we play ok let's look at
this is probably wrong queen bee three
mmm that looks bad ok king of a this is
the line that should lead that is it
supposed to be equal so let's set see I
don't really understand anything here
if I'm gained a space there so that he
doesn't have g5 I understand that g54 is
a problem maybe this is the thing and
he's got this yeah the computer display
stuff like that which is of course free
brutal
yeah the night has those two options
heads it's maybe just just an optical
illusion it's may I mean I was just
thinking that must be terrible for black
but maybe it's just um just an optical
illusion that that poses the question
what what went wrong here because this
is definitely clearly better for white
with the two bishops and all those
weaknesses there okay this this this
should be okay 95 looks very normal but
it's definitely not the only move that
stock which wants to play move like that
yeah this is less threatening maybe 95
it's just like obvious but not not doing
that much I was thinking going over to
c4 in order to look at be six would be
helpful it's not that super convincing
this seems to be wrong before if I that
seems to be wrong now I also wasn't sure
in the game if this is right but so a
three I have to play this is a good
strengthening move for sure yeah maybe
this is the key that black doesn't have
any useful moves here the engine gives
f5 which looks pretty awful if you have
to play a move like that it's difficult
to move anything likes Plex pieces are
somewhat restricted efore is probably
giving him down it's probably giving him
additional ideas if he goes back here
then before
coming check and like this and says yes
hey what has a strong initiative here
yeah okay so before in five was was
wrong and this position isn't that great
they're here this isn't great that's 94
night be four ok this is this is just a
bad move it's just a bad idea check joe
barclay you can go to a later winning
cash check check and now it's nice it's
losing well but i didn't play that well
you 45 this what's this what's wrong
it's really a completely wrong idea in
this position okay thanks for watching